oh I got a good feeling about this
dungeons of dragons is that classic
hero's journey we've got a ragtag group
of Misfits Where we have to fight
dragons and evil wizards in order to
save the world well how do we pull that
off uh figure it out over a drink
probably best
it's about finding your own hero within
and each character has their own version
of that Journey
got him now
is it exactly that you bring to this I'm
a planner I make plans I will not be
complicit in the illicit use of
ill-gotten booty can someone else ride
next to this guy I think there's a
wicked sense of humor through this and
that allows us to have as much fun with
this as we can
I'm glad he's on our side the nuances
that each individual actor brings is
what makes this film so great
this I give you now trusting that you're
protected with your very life
I will
hold this
[Music]
I'm part of the ruthless sand of Thieves
but he's not as evil as the red Wizard
never put your trust in a con man
The Dungeons and Dragons World has
amazing creatures in this one I think
they outdid themselves
these creatures are the same you really
can tell they put a lot into this what
is that again it's now there
[Music]
this is just big fun movie making
it's a great adventure the characters
that you're going to care about we want
to give them the movie that they've been
hoping for that's what I've been saying
yeah
yeah it's pretty badass
[Music]